anyway joining us now with reaction
House Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy
well that didn't take long let's have
another investigation
that's all they want to do you know when
the administration came down to breathe
the house about coronavirus they were
preoccupied with impeachment instead of
protecting this country that's exactly
the only thing they focused upon and
then you watch Nancy Pelosi I watched
her sit there and say those words and it
was very upsetting to me as an American
not as an elected official but as an
American because she is the one who flew
in on Sunday I was in that meeting she
stopped the relief she restricted any
relief for coming unless she could
invoke her liberal wish list into a
reality she talked about changing
election law she talked about Planned
Parenthood she talked about paying off
pensions this is why she held back why
millions of Americans lost their job we
just now got this two trillion dollar
bill through the president has signed it
you're watching things come to fruition
right now with the regulations coming
out and she's wanting to spend trillions
more instead of letting this go to work
and our real focus should be on the
health of this nation and its citizens
and then after we get through this if
there is a targeted area but she is
upset because she did not get that wish
list when you talk about the Kennedy
senator and others the real upsetting
part that she has is all the things she
couldn't put in and remember what her
number three set this is a time to
change the scope and the direction of
this country into their belief to
restructure it was his actual words no
and we saw what they did with the money
I'd like to see how this pans out
obviously I couldn't believe they the
people they were hurting or frontline
hospital workers hourly workers that are
displaced that have mortgages and rents
and car payments and kids in college and
then small business owners and big
businesses so I could only imagine what
their wish list is here should we let
this play out a little bit 2.2 trillion
is a lot four trillion loan guarantees
backed by the Fed is a lot also think
about what you have here
90% of this bill was already decided the
core part that would help Americans
they're going to get a check directly
from the government if you make ninety
nine thousand dollars or less
if you're unemployed you know what
you're going to get you're going to get
taken care of you're going to get six
hundred dollars more per week from the
federal government outside of what your
state provides you but what we really
want to make sure is that you stay on
the job so any small business owner
we're going to provide you the money yes
it's alone but you know what if you
spend that money and you don't have to
go to the SBA go to your local bank we
guarantee it if you spend it on your
employees your rent utilities it's no
longer alone it's a grant into larger
businesses those over 500 employees we
secure your loan but we give you a tax
benefit well we pay for half of your
employees this is all for two months get
us through this time period get this
economy back going to where it was
before the strongest economy in the
world alright thank you I'll congressman
appreciate all your efforts here